hello everybody my name is Margo lion
welcome back to the forest with
jacksepticeye say hi jack
hi jack everybody uh everyone who needs
to do that wait can I kill you
this isn't your no no oh oh
because I hate acts I saw you and my
instinct was just to swipe so I can't it
can't be blamed yeah well we start back
at the plane if you die yeah okay well I
mean if we make our camp by the plane
which is what every single person who
ever said anything in the comments
section of any video I ever did this may
camp by the plane because we're idiots
that's it long and short of it oh you
make it by the beach why by the beach
people always said by the beach but
finding available B to fish at was
actually harder and it took me longer to
get there than anything a viable Beach
viable viable be viable whatever it's
English it's varies from country to
country don't blame me either you're
Irish have a tennis ball have a tennis
ball I already had it done it yeah
is there still oh I didn't see yeah hey
hey I'm over here now stop that Congrats
the way you're flowing as well does it
not work well with water know is it's
not that advanced don't you know
smartphones
we're cave people now yeah in Bunga get
fish there we go you can't see the fish
of my screen that are in your screen no
can you know is it on the end of your
stick yeah here's gonna pretend I'm not
in feet it'll numb that was a good fish
little salty if you know what I mean but
anyway you're like sushi right oh love
it is that a racist joke he's saying cuz
I'm Asian
no you're that's that's Japanese you're
Korean
shut up yeah you're right hey I love it
I love it I love zoo I know more Korean
than you do which is shameful for you
because your girlfriend's green right
yeah you're like you're like half Korean
you should know someone I know you ever
say Oh which is hello yeah it's like a
polite way to say hello and then there's
a non polite wait it's the it's the
phone call way of saying hello yeah
though if you in someone on the street
if you meet someone on the street you
say annyeong as hey oh that's right on
y'know sale and the impolite way is just
[ __ ] you how you doing
hey there's lawn chairs Oh what's up
grab a grab a beer
wait what is this I have not played this
in a while what I'm gonna say to the
audience out there is that it's been a
long time since I played there's been
numerous numerous up you game
whoa what the hell is the point of this
ha oh god I almost hit you sorry Jesus
the animosity is already begun so weary
come here Larry Larry oh good he didn't
put up much of a fight to me see how he
fell over yeah he just stood up on his
button was like oh how could you in fell
backwards slowly no I needed to say it I
could've just put it in a replay or
something sometimes I forget yes it's
also Larry oh god he's here all right
doesn't give a [ __ ] he just like kill me
please
I don't wanna be on this island anymore
kill me please I can't blame him not
exactly those friendlier places okay so
hot here so we are legitimately gonna
try to find everything that's new in
this game and we're gonna try to do what
it takes to survive first yeah even kill
the bunnies don't well alright if you're
gonna eat them for food than I I sure
I'm sure you can oh he's putting up a
fight easy knowing where'd he go where'd
he go where'd he go resisting arrest
we're gonna go here yes I get him I get
him good yes hey I'll get call to meet
you thank you for how assist you thank
you oh you are the assistant in this
this is why is your face all green
you're like camouflaged as well am i
wearing like camo gear no you're not
you're wearing a t-shirt you got a
little bit of a pouch going on in your
stomach area you got a wrist brace I'm
sure you play video games way too much
and you got yeah you're wearing like a
camouflage like show that you want you
in charge Halen's okay we need to make a
camp do you want to make it by a beach
yeah we need to find like the beach with
the boat cuz this cave we is the flare
gun still here the flare gun with
unlimited flares it's still in the game
I don't know if it doesn't limited
players but we have like we have tree
houses we have gazebos
we have bows and arrows now doing some
it's amazing it's been how many how many
episodes of this have you made 10 10
oh man I've only made three three four
and my second one was just complete
insanity like I had no idea what I was
doing and I was not getting anywhere so
I recorded for like an hour and a half
and I I didn't even want to put the
episode up but I cut it into this weird
amalgamation of awfulness it just went
up and people took it for what it was
just I didn't livestream so yeah yes
more experience in those few videos I
totally forgot I did it in a livestream
that's true I build a log cabin that was
like my whole ki know more about you
than you do I don't remember half of
those stuff I do I'm dead serious yeah
it's weird or weird yeah oh this here's
the pile of luggage have they added any
more to the island itself I don't think
so I don't you still can't find Little
Billy
oh yes all ended by cannibals oh yeah
that's what this game is about God okay
Oh doing I don't leave you alone for two
minutes did you see what was happening
there no but you're freaking out weird
look anyway I got a rock head take that
I don't know what I'm gonna eat my candy
you a piece of candy piece of candy okay
this is gonna make some audit tubs yeah
you wait what how do you know how much
to make already why aren't you telling
me the leader what to make where the
leader the ladders did you I have to
throw this at you I know for a fact that
does nothing so go ahead wait you don't
have to know if it molotovs no uh well I
did I built it before I know I did it's
like booze and rags inside drank oh yeah
Oh your grace Cupid Izzy I drank the
booze accidentally though yeah I'm the
Irish one here I'm half German even
though I'm hoping allergic to alcohol
wait what yeah no some Koreans like half
of all Koreans can't process alcohol
correctly so they get really red in the
face and their heart rate picks up in it
okay well the [ __ ] the Koreans I met
or well aim the drink well good
you that's the other half and I
north-south half I'm talking about just
like I'm half German so you'd think my
German side would override any inability
to process alcohol but unfortunately I
have a rough time with it like one one
beer will knock me down if I don't take
these special pills before I do anything
Oh what you're not seeing a boat no I
see a thing sticking out of the ground
is this a boat okay no I'm gonna go out
to the boat on the shore and I might
there's a boat right here in front of me
you're lying you got be nicer you're
you're you're flying in the sand
I just wanted you to know that you're
really nice like no water this is a
barren wasteland you are hallucinating
my friend Wade you receive water I don't
see water Jesus there's no water okay
there's birds flying into the beach down
there if that's what you're talking
about it's just a really long beach man
yeah okay well there's water like I'm
standing right at the edge of the water
I have no ideas there a shark am i
walking towards a shark right now yeah
oh sure you're joking with I don't know
if it has even the boat the boat is
really far out am i swimming in the air
swimming in the air in Jesus I think
some translation got lost sending all
the game information from Ireland to me
yeah see that's why I hosted know you
get all day crazy hallucinogenic stuff
maybe the boat I'm having the boat look
like some mush are you're not gonna make
it I'm gonna see you just get torn in
half in the yeah let's party what's
gonna have weird the Sharks gone there
were sharks nothing disappeared I only
see birds and lizards crawling out there
there's bunny rabbits I might like
floating way above the ground right now
healthy you are it's amazing how are you
doing that how are you doing that it's a
magic trick
I'm a wizard huh wow it's really far
away well maybe maybe if you guide me to
where it is cuz I can run if you didn't
notice it down you'll see me sprinting
full speed twenties what I'm underwater
okay look turn around turn around I'm
down underwater I can't see you turn
around I did okay I go off with her here
I'm here
where should put the boat is like above
your head you're going past it now where
is it
yeah it's right here it's like right
where I am now haha am i standing on it
oh wait okay get on the podium silly you
hey I'm on the weird I'm on the boat you
can see up your crotch right now you'd
only get Marky move underneath hey you
know you would pay for mark EMU to be
under them you know you know that's
weird
takes ah hey come on at least you're
away from the freaking rain yeah
whatever
I don't even I hear rain I don't see
rain okay head back yeah I'm going to
what I'm going to do what I was
underneath it
I'd ov I'm gonna say dived I have I'm
gonna get out of here because I feel
like I might be drowning or something
and I better focus on building the camp
I'll be the homemaker right you can play
Al and Cher hey street sharks was a
great show they may remember sharks
awesome Street sharks wat cats
uh what was the other one there that was
I can't now you lost me do you never
seen SWAT Kats no Oh SWAT Kats was
awesome it's cheesy biker mice from mars
no no I didn't see that
oh that's all Irish Bowl over there no
it's not a name realism Airy where Ana
least we both saw Street tracks that was
cool wait no biker mice biker mice yeah
I remember biker mines okay I just I can
Lyons hey nothing's real until I
remember it so just leave me we need to
survive yes build a fire wait are you
building it out there no I'm just
following you I was killing another
lizard well here's I have a strong
affinity for lizards okay that's good
for you since I only know barren
wasteland I'll start chopping down the
trees at the edge here and hopefully
they'll roll down the hill okay I catch
them in my mouth
yes please do you did that one time you
know you were oh yeah sharks sharks I
don't see sharks
thirsty they didn't pop in yet there's
three day tracks over here I can't seem
to swing my axe 'very oh I'm out of
breath okay you're out of health it was
Lee
oh he's some Pandi he's some candy oh
yeah I forgot
let me do I forgotten everything about
this game so I've heard these sharks
glitch out I'm gonna see if these glitch
out uh-huh
kept going to rakia fat-ass good have
you been killed Bob whoa God do it was
the scariest thing I've ever experienced
in my life
like seriously no joke that is one of my
biggest fears to be stranded out in the
middle of the ocean with no one around
yeah waiting for the shark that you
can't see to touch you I get scared in
the deep end of the pool like you think
an ocean wall you're one of those people
of course I'm one of those people I swim
great but god damned if I can't see the
bottom I am terrified for my life oh no
dogs no logs no dogs ere we go
no logs No I'm telling them not to roll
away on me don't you roll away on me
okay yeah you you keep yelling lizard on
it
the lizard roll down I killed a lizard
when did I kill lizard you just smack
the lizard my mistake
oops my bad I'm just uh eco-terrorist
out here killing all the animals and
trees die fire time fire time why do I
have your your goals of inventory I
don't want to know what you need to
gather fine it's how we're in this
together
oh [ __ ] me trees did you chop - what are
you talking about there's like a whole
freaking aviary here I would love that
or for tchard if I could just get a
chainsaw somehow in this guy I just be
building a fire next thing out here's a
knitted Indian it turned into a horror
game really quickly at night hello jack
what was that game huh oh you go outside
and just like a cornfield and then the
chainsaw yeah those oh I just posted the
animation of that uh it was oh yeah I
kosis yeah
legality and has ever done for me for me
now is that first ever but for me it was
amazing house blown away by like he you
would say that it's probably you know
not his best work considering he's but
he's refined his animation since then
but still us one
funniest I've ever seen love it love
them to death I'm gonna get somebody to
animate for me I like animations they're
cool to watch do it yeah call out like
right now to say if anyone out there is
an animator that wants you know work
like we like I pay lik see and to make
animations for me oh yeah I'm definitely
I don't expect anyone to do it for free
I wouldn't dream of it like it is no way
if I can post it on my channel like
obviously you know I get ad revenue from
it and I get subscribers from it because
people share that stuff
well yeah I'm super grateful of by the
way you guys are awesome but yeah I
think we're dicks for that sake oh they
did it for you and you get all the money
ya know we pay like I paid yeah you know
good about I won't say exactly how much
but I pay him solid work for what he
does
and how quickly he does it like so if
anyway animator out there wants to like
get worker make animation for us you
know we always link back to your
channels yeah we'd love to see it
heck animate this series maybe yeah but
gets super funny down the road maybe not
so much now but maybe down there who
knows what except applier Mart hey
people already ship that you don't need
to do anymore - yeah hey I am trying to
remember the name that they said Jack
applier know that sounds like
masturbation um Jack cept applier
jacksepticeye ur mark you know you guys
can make them whatever you're kept Takei
that's oh yes you're nothing
your name is a little awkward - combined
with everything please name is not the
most pleasant on the ears I I'll admit
that I'll say that yeah well is you just
imagine a giant pulsating I wouldn't be
yeah bad full of septic what is yeah
yeah you've got you've had met you've
had a thing made by that coyotes eat
right I thought you were gonna say I had
a sceptic before I was like god no you
had there like the source filmmaker
stuff made right coyote Mason and a few
other source filmmakers guys have made
some stuff about my games yeah that's
one of the guys who I'm why do I hear
you in-game what'd you hear me in-game
yeah you're doubling oh your
walkie-talkie out sorry
questions walkie-talkie I would hear
amazing you Mary
Jennifer this is your father to me
sounds like you're doing like a whole
way
shouting at me hey I'm your boss now
Jack you listen why oh hey I think I see
water Jack Wade oh never mind it's just
a ripple in the horizon I'm losing it it
has always been there
we're gonna be in this a long time jack
we're all just lady behind you we got it
what oh hey hello pretty lady that's
cause you didn't turn off your megaphone
sorry
what are you doing whoa what he doesn't
mean it how does a be joking how did he
die it's real and Molotov atham oh honey
money no Bonnie no I didn't see the foam
I gotta the buddies birdie the prairies
the money all right bunny seems fine is
there fire here that is oh but it's gone
it's gone now oh hey Jill I was hitting
her Wow social courage everyone okay no
runnin hi I see my head trashed
I seem to go insane a lot on these
playthroughs I'd rather get stuff done
if you know what I mean okay
wait what get busy working and stop
getting dying well the night's almost
done we need to make well there's
another guy on the other side we got it
oh he's a Crawley okay see anything I
can see everything except the water in
fire apparently it's dark here I don't
take out my lighter not cuz I smoke yeah
no smoking is bad just Lord 20 and
learning and some of you may be the logs
in it Rock uh what are we building I
don't know what do you want to build I
you're the one who has seen more than
this do you wanna build a snowman
how about absolutely okay yeah I know
you didn't expect that but I wasn't you
hate that idea no I'd really like to
build a do you know I usually build tree
houses
yeah the betamerica I'm Eric why aren't
you helping teach a lesson cuz I wanna
talk about I don't kill you well get
your ex out there's a lot of things you
could do to help
Oh swinging and missing at you he did
dad you got to make sure okay
okay sigh I guess this would be a good
spot to end it then considering we're
about to be mauled to death by people
yeah so
oh yeah this should be a fun for the
next episode thank you all so much for
watching they're gonna burn the burning
are they burning now no I miss okay
we'll sit check out Jack's channel in
the description below thank you all
again and as always we'll see you in the
next one the planes and jazz was a
creepy guy who ended by Pisco I got it
uh-huh I got it